okay um hi everyone my name is Jones Kim
early the Google Play games partnership
for the truck in Tokyo as you may know
Japan is one the largest market in the
space of more gaming and that is true
for Google prayer as well looking at
successful games in the Japan market
he's actually bring a really big role
and the developers are putting it at the
center of their growth strategy and a
more interesting read what are you doing
for Rev ups is sometimes quite good and
from those in the western regions so
today I'm going to talk about the latest
trends of robots in Japan and also
Cherokee insights and the best practices
run from there
okay so here's today's agenda for you
so on the first of all I'm going to talk
about what the lab ops is and explain
why it's important for you as a game
developers and then I'm going to explain
a bit about a key market difference
between Japan and the Western Europe and
then move on to the case studies from
Japan and the lessons run from there
so what is robots I think many of you
have already heard of this definition
but the RAI bob says running games as a
service the characteristics of the
smartphone has an always connected
device actually all the game developers
to frequently interact with the end
users by providing additional content
and information as a service which does
not necessary involves the transition
apk updates so when these services are
provided in the right way it actually
drives user engagement stimulates
monetization and even reduce it the
prayer churn which has a significant
impact on the life cycle of your game so
what happens when the service is not
enough when your end users so this is
the typical revenue trend curve that the
games that you know delivers content
only if your charger API updates but not
beer
wry bobs for each update you see you
know some spikes in revenue but it's
Rosanne pretty fast and you cannot
maintain active users by the next update
and the spike size gets more and more
each time we call this a shopping cart
program
and obviously this is not ideal if you
want to make your game sustainable so in
one way does wrap-up solve this problem
so ripe up is basically the strategic
distribution of frequent content updates
in between these graduate decay updates
these are basically categorized into two
things the sales and events and the both
of them
often contains a new content into your
game economy and typically the DS are
provided you know in a limited time
basis so which is a key for you to
motivate your users to you know the
participate actively in the activities
happening inside your game when these
cells and events are provided in the
right way rivals can drive a consistent
herpe of revenue and engagement and
which helps you to avoid shark link-up
problem for your game okay so that is
robots and from here I drag to touch a
bit about the key market difference
between Japan and the West in Europe
what's unique about Japan in the context
of live ups so first of all Japan is the
really robbed of City market compared
with the western regions and its deadly
revenue fluctuates a lot due to the high
frequency of the live ups one of the
reasons behind this is the popularity of
the gotcha model the gotcha is the
Ingham rotary system which is widely
adopted to the you know top grossing
Japanese games as a core monetization
mechanics because Gacha is a really good
fit with limited time sells and events
so Japanese developers run a lot of
these as a you know driver for their
revenue and monetization of course
they're also running a lot of other
types of events wreck in-game roving
bonus and in-game quests but the gotcha
is something we cannot ignore as an
important part of Japanese wrap-ups
culture and another reason for the huge
fluctuation of dairy revenue in Japan is
the first day of the month Spike's
tradition Japan is known as a country
where DCB is very popular form of
payment among the mobile users
and as you know the DCP has a monstery
cap so if you hit the cap in the middle
of the month you had to wait until the
next first day of the month you know
because the cap gets refreshed on that
day so knowing that timing Japanese
developers always bring the most
powerful Rob's event on the first day of
the month and the Japanese users also
know that is the best timing to use
money in the game so the combination of
this developer strategy and user
behavior actually comes together and
always calls it the huge ribbon spike on
the first day of the month for most of
the games altogether which is pretty
unique for the Japan market I think okay
so here's a quick quiz regarding the
uniqueness of Japanese wrap ups I
mentioned that Japan is pretty drab of
city market but how many ingame Rob's
events were actually done by a single
top grossing Japanese title in the month
of March 2017 it would be great if you
guys can participate a quiz by raising
your hands who thinks a rest on ten no
one be ten to fifty you see fifty two
hundred three hundred to two hundred
looks popular and E over two hundred
okay seems right D and E are the most
popular options here so let's did answer
the answer is e congratulation for those
who chose e sorry no price for this
Chris no t-shirts
okay I think now you guys interesting
what the exact number is so let's see
the exact number in the next right
the answer is 1028
thanks for the reaction yeah
actor thousand events in the month which
sounds like a big number and this is
just an example but now you see how
serious and how committed Japanese games
are regarding the communication with the
users through drive ups so from here I'm
going to talk a bit about a case stories
from actual Japanese top crossing
James to do a beam or deep dive into the
array of strategies the first one is the
monster strike by Nick CX rock studio
the one of the most popular and
successful Japanese games cysteines
watch four years ago oh this is a quick
overview of the monster strikes wrap-up
c-band in a given month as you can see
there running sundry bobs events in the
month which ranges from the gotcha
event for monetization and the burst
size of the in-game quest for the
purpose of the engagement up rift what's
interesting here to me is the deer
running so many system and gorilla event
the which is basically an hour or a
Heuer song super short micro quest
operated systematically you know if you
run rake 900 event in a month by money
or you know you need a lot of work and
it's almost impossible so mixi actually
design a game
from the scratch to be able to offer
this microbe quest effectively and
efficiently by system and automation so
that they are able to you know deploy
such a large number of quests in amounts
however please think about it if you
have like hundreds of drive often your
game it is very easy for your users to
get lost if they don't understand which
what matters for them so it is very
important for you to organize the lab
ops event to abort your users get
swamped by the front of the box so from
the next try I'm going to introduce you
how mixi is actually designed the lab
ops calendar in the eerie boundary and
the dairy basis okay the first one is
eerie cycle for the character based game
wreck monster strike the best content
for monetization is always additional
rajendra tractor which has a significant
break skills and parameters so mixi
basically runs this type of fraction
heavy you know rebels gotcha events
every three months is considering the
seasonality and so on according to mixi
the ones in three months is is car
magic number from their four years
experience because if users are exposed
too frequently to dis knows this type of
heavy events they get tired of catching
up and eventually the game so rather
than increasing the number of these
heavy Rob's events the mixi rather
focuses on maximizing the ribbon spike
for each of them and the zooming into
the monster each cycle
monster strike January has a consistent
bit of the revenue spike in the
bi-weekly basis this is because they are
following you know the first day of the
month spike tradition in the Japan
market and also press the mid-size dry
bobs in between these two keep your core
users engaged precisely speaking they're
actually running a lot of other events
in between these but they stick to this
cadence for the stronger gotcha event to
keep the good rhythm of excitement for
their core users which is especially for
the paying users and they also cares a
lot about when to deploy what kind of
events in a day from the relevancy point
of view for example that they deployed
the gotcha events typically around the
launch time because they want you know
their users who just got a new character
through the Gotcha to show off that to
your real friends who are eating the
lunch together and the hope free parade
our game together and on the other hand
the regarding the quest that requires
some reverb concentration they typically
deployed these or on the commute time or
after the dinner when users typically
play the game alone with a lot of
concentration so in these ways
mixie is carefree designing the live
obscure endure to help their users enjoy
the surfing on the barest size of the
waves of the live ups so now let's do a
bit more deep dive into there one of the
flagship reverbs even which happens only
once in three months is the example here
is a special Gacha event which future
the new rage injury character called
Pandora that this cute go
and this event was especially successful
for mixi because it draw a hundred fifty
percent year-on-year increase in revenue
so Arista cricket mixes efforts behind
this peak moment the first one is a
quantity control of in-game currency is
owned by users when you have like huge
monetization moment in your game in
terms of ribose it is very important to
create an ideal status of the in-game
economy beforehand for example if users
have too many and consumed in-game
currencies already they just spend this
when Reb ops comes in and they don't
really purchase new I ap which could be
a problem for your monetization so Mick
she actually tracks the quantity of
in-game currencies owned by users as one
of the key metrics and accumulated the
small Rev ups before the Frog ship you
know the gotcha event and created ID or
state of in-game economy prior to the
big monetization moment or a game and
also they went beyond in-game operations
and it out of the games media mix
activities to promote the lab ops event
for example this character Pandora was
introduced first in the YouTube anime of
monster strike three days before the
actual in-game event and then the
details of the characters break skills
and parameters called rebuilt in their
in-house increments a video on the
YouTube and then if it TV commercial was
air to more to promote this wrap ups
campaign after that a noise sounds like
a lot of investment but for mix II
actually thought they are very natural
thing because they are putting it at the
center of their monetization strategy
and even more
they added several significant marketing
activities before the Pandorica event
which increased massive giveaway of
in-game items and even the real good
racket robotica to the active users of
the monster strategy in the hard
decisions and also the ROG skillful
community event in the eSports
tournament which gathered over 220
thousand people
in Tokyo on-site these marketing
activity were not directly related to
this specific Gacha event but the
strategy appraised before that to
maximize the active user base - you know
that make the the big monetizing moment
of death so what's the result by doing
all of these so here's a chart you would
be interested in actor Iman so strike
had been facing the steep decline of the
demands free active user base for the
first half of the 2016 however the by
providing the good mix of in-game
operations and out of the game marketing
activities they could achieve the
beautiful reshaped recovery of the
monthly active users and it resulted in
the great financial success of the
Pandora Gacha event after that you know
when talking about Rui Bob's people
tended to focus too much on the just
in-game activities but actually it
drives more impact on your business if
it's nicely branded with the out of the
game's marketing activities so this is
very good example I think okay so that
was the Pandora Gacha event example and
let me talk about some other cases as
well when talking about Japan unique
grab ups culture IP collaboration is
something I cannot ignore which is very
popular among Japanese developers for
example corroborating was popular games
IP comic IP anime IP is very popular
among Japanese games because it is very
effective to bring the new surprise to
your existing audience base and also
reach out to the entire new audience
space through the power of the different
IP and this kind of cooperation can also
happen with the non game of frying
bronze as well this is my favorite
example but the monster strike actually
collaborated with the Baskin Robbins
resin tree a popular ice cream franchise
store and they actually created a
special quest in the game and the when
users clear the the quest they could get
the free ice cream cube
is that a game and if I'm not biased
everyone loves ice cream right so um the
actually monster strike could make their
users happy by giving away a free ice
cream and in return baskin-robbins could
drive the actual people to the store and
even you know enhance their brand
awareness with this this case is quite
interesting to me because it shows me
how wide the scope of rev ups is if it
makes sense for you and your partner you
can even distribute your ice cream to
your users in a context of light bulbs
okay so that was the mixi case and I
drag to introduce you another case from
the other Japanese developer clear of
and the game is breach brave souls when
designing robots taking a data-driven
approach it's really effective and
important so here I drag to introduce
you how sophisticated developers were
care of is designing the effective
reverbs based on the insights gained
Street in-game data log and Arctic's
this slide shows the basic kpi's at the
care of the Nordics team is ricky net
which includes monetization KPI eric
revenue and their PPU and engagement
KPIs for external 8 and the new user
kpi's including installs and 7 their
attention to extract key insights scarab
an arctic steam actually look at these
KPIs
from four different user segmentation
angles which includes in-game status
install timing login frequency and the
spin wrench here I drag the introducing
one interesting case where a care of
team found the very good inside the
kidnapped in-game stators segmentation
so breach brave soul has a character a
build up function called a skill board
and the care of team found that the
combination of this skill board
progression and the maximum rarity of
the character that the users own it's
actually one of the best angles to look
at the health status of the overall
in-game balance
when they look at you know key
engagement kpi's from this user
segmentation angle they found that the
users who own the sixth or BRT tractor
but hasn't completed the skill board yet
actually has a significant turn rate
compared with other group lost groups of
users and even worse this group of
people represented represented to over
20% of the total consumer spent for this
game so it was a problem so to solve
this problem the Carib added new quest
that help users to complete the sixth er
skill bore easily and by doing so the
users who complete the skill bore and go
up to the next rebel actually increased
from 4% to nine point seven percent
month-over-month
and even significant tree the churn rate
of this specific group decreased by
eleven point eight percent compared from
the previous months as I said this group
of users represented the 20% of the
total consumer spend so now you see how
impactful it was for the bridge perhaps
all team okay so it was quick but hope
you enjoy some fresh case studies share
from the mixi and the care of team so
now I drag to summarize the today's key
takeaways from these case studies so
here's four key pillars
I talked today the first one is the
rivals design so if you want to make the
most out of the live ups you have to
design your game with rival team mine I
think mixes system event functionality
is one of the great example of doing
this and also you have to design
strategy soccer bribe ops you if you try
to run a lot of wrap ups otherwise your
users get swamped by the fraud table box
and also the controlling game economy
which is very important so you shouldn't
forget about it and the sir go beyond
simple drive ups when talking about Rui
Bob's people tend to focus too much on
you know just in game activities but
when it's nicely branded ways out of the
game marketing activities you can act
more impact on your business and the
cooperation with other IPS and bronze
could be an interesting idea for you if
you want to reach out to the entirely
new audience base and the last three you
use their behavior it's always a great
source of insight so if you want to be
really effective and efficient in
creating the new RIE Bob's events for
your game
taking a data-driven approach would work
pretty well for you okay so thanks for
reasoning that's all from me today so if
you have any questions I will try to
take these
you